Yeah, this one actually
has very subtle symptoms.
About 45% of the loss
in cocoa in West Africa
is by pests and pathogens.
Of that, 15% in 2009 was
attributed to the virus.
It's spreading so fast
that it's hard to fathom
how we can really
stop it right now.
It's fun to play with chocolate.
Getting all messy, and the
smell of it is just sensational.
It makes me happy
to work with it.
There's just been
some real crises
at the level of the farmers,
of their socioeconomic status.
So we're worried about
having our chocolate crop.
But if they're
leaving the business
because they can't
make a living,
or they're diversifying
into other crops, which
is what they're doing,
over the period of time
that we see in the
near future there
could be less and less
chocolate planted there.
Chocolate is in
almost every dessert
we think of, and is one of those
staples of any type of dessert
we talk about, from birthdays to
holiday celebrations and things
like that.
If we think about
Valentine's Day,
pretty much it's
all about chocolate
on that particular holiday.
And we're able to show
that, in fact, this
is a complex of viruses, as
many as six and probably more.
I'm optimistic.
I think we can do this.
We hope that the
contribution we're making
is going to make a
difference to the farmers
and downstream, of course,
to the supply of chocolate.
Chocolate isn't just
used for sweets.
It's also used for
savory items too.
It is one of those interesting
flavors that adds enhancements
to a lot of different foods.
So, say a world
without chocolate,
it's almost like taking
salt away and saying
you can use it forever again.
Back in the day, if you will,
when the Mayans and things
like that were the only ones
that was doing the cocoa bean
itself, it was used as currency.
Because you can imagine
chocolate becoming maybe
a currency again,
if you would, or one
of those really special
gifts that you give only
on special occasions.